russia is under close scrutiny this
morning after a video call between
president biden and vladimir putin the
president warned the russian leader of
dire consequences if he orders an
invasion of ukraine and he may satellite
images indicate russia has been amassing
troops near ukraine's border raising
alarms among our nato allies ed o'keefe
is following all this from the white
house for us ed good morning tony good
morning welcome back the white house
says it lasted two hours and that the
president issued a direct warning that
the u.s and its european allies are
willing to go farther than ever before
to hold russia accountable if it attacks
ukraine
hello
good to see you again
the meeting between president biden and
vladimir putin came as the world waits
to see what the russian leader might do
with his troop buildup along the
ukrainian border the president's
national security adviser jake sullivan
attended the meeting he told president
putin directly that if russia further
invades ukraine the united states and
our european allies would respond with
strong economic measures sullivan warned
the u.s could send military equipment to
ukraine and boost an already existing
american troop presence in eastern
europe and he hinted at stronger
economic retaliation than when russia
annexed crimea in 2014. things we did
not do in 2014 we are prepared to do now
much of this comes right out of putin's
2014 playbook
under secretary of state victoria
newland told senators that these
satellite images are what's causing so
much concern newland says they confirm
the massive buildup of tens of thousands
of russian troops along ukraine's
donbass region we must prepare with our
allies and partners for all
contingencies a putin spokesman said the
russian leader once again demanded that
ukraine never become a part of nato but
the white house said president biden
didn't agree to that concession still
former u.s ambassador to ukraine stephen
pifer expects the biden administration
will be watching for signs of russian
retreat the biggest sign would be
does the russian military begin to draw
back away from ukraine but also and
perhaps more quickly do you begin to see
a change in the rhetoric coming out of
moscow which has been pretty over the
top the last week
the white house says the president plans
to speak with ukraine's leader about all
of this tomorrow and with the russian
threat looming the house last night
overwhelmingly passed a 768 billion
dollar annual defense bill that includes
new aid to boost ukraine nate
a story we will be keeping our eyes on
ed thank you